our world is constantly changing many
scenes in our everyday lives that are
seemingly static in fact contain subtle
variations and changes that are
invisible to us imagine you had special
glasses that allowed you to see subtle
changes that cannot be seen with the
naked eye like small variations in the
color of the skin has blood pulsates
through it or the subtle breathing
motions of a baby these changes are
hidden in ordinary videos we capture
with our cameras and smartphones given
an input video for each pixel we analyze
the color variation over time and
amplify this variation which gives us a
magnified version of video
in this example the pulse signal is
amplified 100 times
we can also analyze the frequencies of
this signal and extract the heart rate
this doesn't require attaching any
sensors to the patient and the accuracy
is comparable with hospital grade
monitors
the same algorithm can also reveal
imperceptible motions like the pulsing
motions of arteries in the wrist
when a person fixates at a point the IMA
move from subtle head motions or from
involuntary eye movements known as
microseconds such motions are very hard
to notice even in this close-up shot of
the eye but become apparent when
amplified 150 times invisible motions
are also created by mechanical parts
such as the shutter and flipping mirror
in a DSLR camera that produce tiny
motions when taking pictures
structures are designed to sway in the
wind but their motion 2 is often
invisible amplifying the changes in this
video reveals the swaying of the cranes
mast and the undulation of its hook
you